here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Austin Butler and Elvis
Colin Farrell in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
Brendan Fraser in the whale
Paul meskel and after sun
and Bill Nye in living
and now the five nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Kate Blanchett in tar
Anna De armas
Andrea reisborough into Leslie
Michelle Williams in the fablemans
and Michelle yo in everything everywhere
thank you
just two categories Remain the first is
achievement in directing and the
nominees are
Martin McDonough the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Daniel Kwan and Daniel sheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Steven Spielberg the fablemans
Todd field tar
and Reuben usland triangle of sadness
now the final category
here are the ten nominees for best
motion picture of the year
right on the Western Front mounted Blue
Notes producer
Avatar the way of water James Cameron
and John Landau producers
the Banshees of inner Sharon Graham
Broadbent Pete Charmin and Martin
McDonough producers
Elvis baslerman Catherine Martin Gail
Berman Patrick McCormick and Schuyler
Weiss producers
everything everywhere all at once Daniel
Kwan Daniel sheinert and Jonathan Wong
producers
[Applause]
the fablemans Christy mccosko Krieger
Steven Spielberg and Tony Kushner
producers
tar Todd field Alexander milshon and
Scott Lambert producers
top gun Maverick Tom Cruise Christopher
Macquarie David Ellison and Jerry
Bruckheimer producers
triangle of sadness Eric hemendorf and
Felipe producers
and women talking
Deedee Gardner Jeremy Kleiner and
Francis McDormand producers
[Applause]